have you noticed how recently Saudi
Arabia Bahrain Abu Dhabi Kuwait Qatar
are interested in buying sports teams
why why do you care about golf why NBA
why MLB why soccer do they know
something we don't know are they running
a printing machine over there that we
don't know about is it just something
they're throwing their money away or is
it an investment they're making how did
UFC when they bought it in 1993 for two
million dollars is now a 12 billion
dollar organization the person that
bought the Cowboys in 1964 million
dollars Cowboys are the most expensive
franchise at eight billion dollars it's
a lot of money being made here what are
the next Sports you ought to think about
is there money and alternative assets
can you get involved in it we're going
to talk all about that today if you get
value out of this video give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel but let's
get right into it look if you're like me
when you first started watching sports
you just love the game like oh my God I
love this game like I watch baseball
saying what a cool game these are the
stats this is awesome wow NBA this is
the countdown this is the shot clock
that's how NHL works three periods
that's how soccer Works what a cool
thing this is and then maybe you and I
experience when you bought your first
pack and you opened it up and you got
this card and it was seven dollars and
then a year and a half later you sold
the car for 28 dollars you're like oh my
goodness from seven to twenty eight
dollars that's three four hundred
percent of money I made as a regular kit
the same way you make your money there
as a kid in baseball cards is the same
way these billionaires are making money
it's the reason why some people are
buying sports teams by the way I'll give
you a quick story here and then we'll
get into all this data I get a call out
of nowhere one day I'm in the office
this guy calls me saying hey are you
interested in Wayne Gretzky I said I'm
happily married he says no no are you
interested in Wayne Gretzky rookie cards
the two best ones out there PSA 10. I
said sure what's the number eventually
me and this owner talk we come up with a
number I end up buying these two cars
for 540 000 I send one of my guys secret
man I trust he goes to La they meet at
PSA headquarters in Newport Beach the
owner brings the cards drops it off we
give them the money we exchange my
friends family wife they're like what
are you doing buying a car for 540 000 I
said first of all alternative assets
Wayne Gretzky the greatest hockey player
of all time there are not too many of
these cars going to be out there this is
a good investment on making and I sat on
it 18 months later you know what we sold
it for at Heritage auctions it was a
world record at the time 2.2 million
dollars I made 300 rate of return in a
span of what 18 months now recently I
became a minority owner of the Yankees
I'm there of course the emotions all
that exciting stuff yes the announcement
great we're in the stadium incredible
feeling celebration I get to call them
Bermuda oh my God I can't believe this
is happening
unbelievable but guess what my
investment already based on me starting
the ownership process at the valuation
of 2022 according to Forbes Yankees
already in 2022 made 18 and that is the
price people buy or sell teams Yankees
the investment in less than a year of me
owning it already made 18 so what is all
this world and Pat I don't have that
kind of money why how can I get involved
in this I understand this is why I'm
kind of getting you to think about this
alternative assets the unconventional
way of making an investment not just to
mute Trump on stocks but so sports teams
MBA started publicly introducing their
valuations of Team prices in 96. MLB and
NFL was 98 and NHL was 2004. let's look
at some of these team prices to see what
kind of increases they've had over the
years so what we did is we took the most
expensive teams in every league and the
least expensive team and we're showing
what kind of rate of return they've had
in the last 20 years Yankees in 2003 was
a 730 million dollar franchise today
it's worth 7.1 billion it's increased
872 percent by the way Yankee
steinburner originally bought it I think
in 1973 for 8.8 million dollars that's a
thousands of percent rate of return in
that organization Cowboys 2003 851
million dollar valuation today 8 billion
an increase of 840 percent the Cowboys
was bought in 1964 1 million dollars
Warriors 176 million 0003 today they're
the most expensive franchise in the NBA
surpassing the Lakers and the Knicks 7
billion dollars an increase of you ready
3877 I believe Shaman sent a tweet he
was a minority owner of the Golden State
Warriors when they first voted for 450
million dollars a few years ago he said
I went in 10 he says my rate of returned
on my 45 million dollar investment I
ended up getting out at around 500
million dollars is what he paid on his
45 million investment I may be a little
bit off on the dollars but the Tweet is
out there for you to find Rangers hockey
250 million in 2003 today 2.2 billion a
rate of return of 923 percent now let's
look at the least valued organizations
in each sport and what the rate of
return has been and MLB Pirates 163
million today they're worth 1.3 billion
a rate of return still 697 Lions 509
today 3 billion that's still a rate of
return of 489 Kings 259 today 2 billion
that's a rate of return of 672 and last
but not least one's a tough one here
coyotes they're not going to like this
they were 150 million dollar
organization on O3 they're only 450
today 200 percent and when you compare
this to the k-shiller home price index
on what kind of rate of return that's
done since 2000 that's only returned 160
and a half percent the s p since 2000
has been around 324 percent and when you
compare it every one of the sports teams
beat out the rate of return SMP is given
as well as real estate by a mile except
for the coyote so what does this tell us
that means alternative assets must be
something you ought to consider if
you're somebody I'd say I'd love to
invest into alternative assets but man I
don't have 10 million bucks I don't have
5 million dollars I don't have a million
dollars maybe I can invest 100 Grand
maybe 10 grand how do I do it
Masterworks is a company that allows you
to buy into Arts Picasso Banksy Andy
Warhol where you buy a share into that
art so if it sells if it goes up makes
whatever kind of returns it is you're
able to participate in that in smaller
fractions as if you're buying a stock
into a company I was at an event in my
Miami with David Solomon and Goldman
Sachs the entire event at Art basil was
all about the alternative Investments
it's something that many many people are
looking at when you see what happened
with S P 500 last year worst year since
2008 in the same exact year auctions
with art had a record-breaking year same
year okay when you see the complete
opposite taking place it's something you
ought to consider if you want to
Masterworks has nearly 750 000 users now
just like any stock you buy Masterworks
does all the work they get every item
that's going to be registered with the
SEC but if you want to consider
participating with Masterworks and
investment click on the link below join
the other 750 000 subscribers that are
part of Masterworks by the way here's a
chart from 2002 how each league does
versus S P 500 if you look at the
numbers S P 500 is the orange one NFL is
green MLB is purple NBA is blue and NHL
is black look at S P 500 2002 versus
2020 SMP is 334 beating out NHL NBA's
all the way at the top at 8 52 MLB is
second at 548 rate of return and NFL is
at 472 percent so what's caused this
increased valuation in these
organizations over the last 10 years
well we look at four things that
determine the revenue of a franchise you
look at meteorites gate Revenue
sponsorships and Merchandising if you
look at this year in 2013 look what was
at the lowest the lowest was that blue
color which represents meteorites then
it was merchandising then it was
sponsorship then gate Revenue but look
at what happened today meteorites went
from last to First merchandising is now
last then you have sponsorship which was
second now it's third and gate Revenue
went from first to second what causes
that eyeballs interest people are
watching this by the way this is one of
the things that the reason why cable is
still around a lot of it is simply
because of sports but wait you see what
Ott is doing watch ticket prices in the
NFL from 2006 to 2022. the average
ticket price in 2006 was 62.38 the
average ticket price today is 111.75 so
let's unpack this meteorites by
different sports and see how big this
number is when you look at the NFL in
2022 the NFL signed a new meteorites
deal with Amazon ESPN Fox CBS and NBC
worth ready
113 billion dollars over 11 years this
is the largest media rights deal in
sports history MLB and 22 signed a new
meteorite steal as well with Fox Turner
Sports ESPN for 30 billion dollars over
seven years this is the largest
meteorite Steel in MLB history MBA in
2021 signed a new meteorite still with
ESPN Turner Sports Amazon for 24 billion
over seven years this was their largest
and by the way there's a special caveat
here because notice how the NBA owners
don't like to bash China you're
wondering why in 2015 the NBA signed a
one and a half billion dollar per year
deal with 10 cents giving it exclusive
rights to broadcast NBA games China's
markets massive I can only imagine what
that could be if these guys are nicer to
China hence they always protect China
there's a reason for it NHL 2021 they
sign a new media rights field with ESPN
TNT and Hulu for 4.9 billion dollars
over seven years this is their largest
but there's the least amount of interest
for NHL simply based on dollars remember
how earlier I said cable is able to be
around because of sports and all the
stuff that we watch on cable and then
Ott got into the sports game watch the
data here on Ott in 2016
Otts were only spending a hundred
million dollars a year on Sports 2017
goes to 400 million then 900 million
then 1.8 billion then 2 billion then 2.9
billion then 5.2 billion estimated eight
and a half billion in 2023 and climbing
and if you look at the numbers in 2023
blue is North American which is doubling
orange is Europe which is about the same
and the rest of the world is the gray
this scares the crap out of cable
because cable companies are sitting
there saying what if these guys no
longer need us or want us and these Ott
companies are able to give the kind of
money we've been given four years we've
got them pulling on this this is not
good so that's one factor you know what
else has changed the game in a big way
massive way sports betting this is the
event the U.S Supreme Court struck down
a federal ban on sports betting in May
of 2018. once they did that it was
Mayhem with sports betting in 2019 900
million dollars in 2020 one and a half
billion in 2021 4.3 billion in 2022
seven and a half billion what do you
think is going to next it'll be 50
billion in no time just sports betting
per year and according to American
gaming.org Major League Baseball alone
stands to gain 1.1 billion dollars in
projected revenue from legal sports
betting NFL is going to gain roughly 2.3
billion NBA could increase by 585
million and NHL could increase by 216
million dollars as if this isn't already
enough look at the kind of companies
that are signing contracts with sports
teams ready NFL in 2019 signed a 10-year
deal with DraftKings NBA in 2021 signed
a 10-year deal with FanDuel MLB in 2023
signed a mo multi-year deal with FanDuel
and NHL in 2022 signed a seven year deal
with bet MGM by the way I got a few
different reasons why this is taking
place but one of the things that's
happened with social media is the world
went from being very big we didn't know
each other to very small the moment
we're all on social so imagine you're in
a complete different country you see a
highlight video for an NFL team here
that's going viral in Germany and that
kid's like that's a pretty cool game I
want to kind of see about NFL now
there's interest in Europe South America
Central America you know Middle East
they're interested in sports more today
because social media expanded the market
and made the world a smaller place
because we're all connected now so now
how are these sports franchises valued
it's based on a few different factors
number one is the popularity of the
sport number two is the success of the
team number three is the strength of the
market number four is the stadium or the
arena number five is team purchase think
about it like if you bought a house for
six hundred thousand dollars five years
later your neighbor sells us out for 2.2
million you're all of a sudden said wait
a minute my house is now worth 2.2
million that's what happened in the NBA
everybody thought their team was worth
three four five hundred million dollars
until Donald Sterling was asked to leave
the NBA and sell his team the Clippers
which was bought by Balmer for 2.2
billion overnight NBA owners were like
thank you Steve Ballmer you made us a
couple billion dollars just because they
bought the clippers for 2.2 billion and
of course you have to consider the
financial strength of the organization
now there's something happening right
now where a lot of the wealthy folks in
America are not too happy about it
because imagine you're able to go buy a
place and you have money you can buy
this place but the other guy's got 50
million dollars he's sitting on cash
you're only sitting on five million
dollars on cash you're like dude I'm
willing to pay you 4 million it's like
you know what I'll overpay about 30
million dollars I'll pay you seven
million dollars you're like I can't pay
seven million dollars but the other guy
can't that's what's happened in sports
right now and here's who's causing it
Sovereign wealth funds are starting to
realize that sports franchises
non-duplicatable assets are becoming
great Investments but some people worry
that Sovereign oil funds from countries
with poor human rights records could use
their ownership of sports teams to
influence American culture and politics
for example the Qatar investment
Authority which owns a stake in the
Washington Wizards has been criticized
for its treatment of Migrant workers in
Qatar meanwhile some people worry that
Sovereign World funds have an unfair
advantage over other investors in the
sports Market this is because they often
have access to large amounts of capital
and can afford to pay higher prices for
sports teams while maybe some people in
America can for example you'll say yeah
that thing's worth 2.2 billion we'll pay
2.4 billion they'll come in and say yeah
it's worth 2.4 billion here's 3.6
billion we're not worried about it you
know what that does like I can't compete
with you what happens to follow a Sunday
by 10 20 30 40 50. what if in the next
20 years these Sovereign wealth funds in
the Middle East on half the teams
literally think about if that actually
takes place now I'm sure someone
eventually is going to go out there and
you know campaign and Lobby and say you
can't have that you know maybe we can
only have 10 of teams or 20 of the teams
but that day is coming let me give you
some stories of what's really taking
place right now Qatar investment
Authority in 2023 acquired a five
percent stake in Monumental sports and
entertainment which owns the Washington
Wizards Washington Capitals and
Washington Mystics Saudi Arabia's public
investment Fund in 2022 card a
controlling stake in Newcastle this is
an English Premier League Bahrain
muntala cat holding company in 2022
acquired a minority stake in Cleveland
Cavaliers Abu Dhabi United group in 2008
acquired Manchester City Kuwait
investment Authority in 2019 acquired a
minority stake in the Dodgers live golf
has paid some players some 800 million
dollars to leave the PGA Tour to join
its team while some may say Pat that's
not a lie that's a small minority amount
I know but it always kind of gets
started like that and like I buy this
land and that land and this land and
holy you want all of it now it
starts like that so we kind of have to
be aware to see who's buying what
because now they're starting to have a
lot of influence so the question becomes
a lot of people may say Pat so what's
left is this it yeah I can't get into
These Guys these are too overpriced yes
but there are other sports and leagues
that are coming out you just have to
watch very close to what's going on
remember earlier I talked about on 1993
they bought UFC for 2 million today it's
a 12 billion dollar organization you
know how much money return that is 10
out of 2 is 20. 100 is 200 a thousand is
2 billion so you got 6 000 times return
on your investment on two million
dollars that's what happened with UFC
what else is this happening to it
happened to MLS there was a big push of
buying MLS organizations the average MLS
top line revenue right now is 45 million
dollars and what people are paying for
is around 12.2 times the top line
revenue it's what the Market's currently
paying for you may say 12.2 okay what's
the big deal with that the average MLS
team you could buy in 1996 for 10
million dollars today the average MLS
team is 550 million dollars but we can
look at other sports or Industries
Esports people like Esports are you
serious yes Esports from 350 million in
2018 to 1.4 billion today pickleball
teams are now selling for five million
dollars Pat pickleball let me give you
some stance on pickleball 36 and a half
million people in America to play
Pickleball in 2023 18-34 largest age
bracket for pickleball players that's 29
153 million dollars of pickleball paddle
Market size in 2021 it's up 159 over
three years 10 320 number of places now
for pickleball to play in U.S and it's
forecasted to grow 7.7 compound annual
growth rate through 2028. that's
pickleball by the way I got approached
by a rugby team saying do you want to
buy a rugby team for three million
dollars because Rugby's going to be
going in America you got lacrosse you've
got a bunch of different things that are
coming this is not going to slow down
you see the whole slap thing the slap
game that's coming that they know why so
yeah we'd be interested in that there's
going to be opportunities keep your eyes
open FYI let this just be an example to
you that you ought to pay attention to
Alternative assets it could be cards it
could be teams it could be art it could
be different things if you can't do it
at the higher level you can go on at a
smaller level but it's definitely
something you ought to pay attention to
if you got value out of this video give
it a thumbs up and subscribe subscribe
to the channel and before you invest
into art watch this video before doing
so take care everybody bye bye
foreign